amélioration. Quelles sont les
pistes de solutions? Jean-
Sébastien Cloutier.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Année après année,
l'état des routes est une source
de frustration à Montréal.
- Pas très belles.
Non, dégueulasses.
- Vraiment dégoûtantes.
Juste à voir mon café, là,
ça brasse dans le camion.
- Ça s'est amélioré?
- Mais c'est... pas à 100 %,
mais c'est mieux que par rapport
à la période de Coderre.
- Il y a plein de trous partout
puis c'est rabiboché un peu
n'importe comment. Moi, j'ai
un petit bébé, pas en ce moment,
mais t'sais, ça me fait peur
parce que son cou fait
tout le temps ça quand je passe
dans les rues de Montréal.
- Deux raisons principales
expliquent l'usure de nos
routes. D'abord, les épisodes de
gel et de dégel. Si de l'eau
s'infiltre dans une fissure et
qu'elle y gèle, la glace fera
bouger la chaussée et créera un
nid-de-poule. Ensuite, le poids
des camions. La présence
de nombreux poids lourds
dans les rues de la ville finit
par endommager les routes.
Alors vous voyez, on est
à l'entrée du pont Jacques-
Cartier. Une route, évidemment,
qui est utilisée par des
milliers d'automobilistes. Et
malgré ça, bien, regardez l'état
de la route. C'est assez triste.
Mais du gel et des camions,
il y en a partout au Canada. Et
pourtant, les routes sont pires
ici. Le CAA-Québec l'a démontré
dans une étude récente.
NICOLAS RYAN, directeur
affaires publiques, CAA Québec
- Concrètement, ce que
ça implique ça dans les poches
des Québécois, c'est un coût de
258 $ par année par véhicule
qui est tiré directement dans
nos poches, donc en entretien
supplémentaire, en coûts
d'essence accru. On est deux
fois au-dessus de la moyenne
canadienne qui est à 126 $.
Nos routes, vous l'avez dit,
sont dans un état qui est
épouvantable.
- C'est pire à Montréal parce
que pendant des décennies,
les administrations en place
ont peu investi dans les routes.
Et Montréal en a plus de
4000 kilomètres à entretenir.
ALAN CARTER, professeur en génie
de la construction, ETS
- On est un peu allergiques
à faire de l'entretien.
On investit clairement pas assez
pour faire autre chose que
du rattrapage, que essayer de
sauver les meubles. Il faudrait
que l'investissement soit
beaucoup plus élevé que ça.
Ailleurs, dans d'autres
endroits, certains États
américains ou dans d'autres
provinces, on met plus d'argent
dans nos chaussées.
- Alan Carter dirige
un laboratoire de recherche
où sont testés plusieurs types
de chaussées.
C'est également pire à Montréal,
ajoute-t-il, parce que
les travaux sont trop souvent
superficiels.
- On dit : c'est la faute
du matériau bitumineux qui a été
mis, mauvaise qualité
ou quelque chose comme ça.
Ce n'est pas le cas.
Une des choses qui est le plus
faite, c'est ce qu'on appelle
un planage resurfacage.
C'est qu'on enlève la couche
du dessus, on enlève vraiment
mince, ça peut être jusqu'à
un 50 mm, mais t'sais, moins que
ça souvent, et on en remet
une couche neuve. Donc on n'a
pas réparé ce qu'il y avait en
dessous, donc ça fait une couche
très mince. Puis quand c'est
très mince, souvent, vous allez
entendre des fois l'expression
du pavage d'élection parce que
ça durera pas très longtemps.
- Cette facon de faire est
fréquente lorsque les cols bleus
interviennent d'urgence pour
réparer un segment de route.
C'est leur rôle. Mais les plus
gros chantiers, eux, sont
effectués par des entrepreneurs
privés. Projet Montréal assure
que leurs contrats sont
maintenant plus exigeants.
Ils doivent vérifier,
entre autres, que les fondations
de la rue sont en bon état
avant de l'asphalter.
BENOIT DORAIS, président sortant
comité exécutif, Ville de Mtl
- Une fois qu'on a dit ça,
est-ce que c'est parfait? Mais
pas du tout, absolument pas. Il
y aucun élu qui peut être fier
en ce moment des chantiers puis
tout ça. Mais il fallait revoir
comment on faisait ça; c'est ce
qu'on a fait. Il faut arrêter
de passer deux puis trois puis
quatre fois sur une même rue.
- Par contre, le parti
de Valérie Plante a coupé dans
le budget d'entretien des routes
depuis deux ans. Il est passé
de 258 millions $ en 2018
à seulement 102 millions
cette année.
- 2020, il y a eu moins de
réparations. Souvenons-nous,
les autorités de santé publique
mêmes nous disaient : écoutez,
des nids-de-poule, nettoyer
des rues, c'est pas essentiel.
Et cette année, l'entièreté
des gens nous ont dit :
il faut s'attarder à la relance
cette année. C'est pas le temps
que la Ville débarque avec un
paquet de chantiers puis nuise,
disons, à l'économie.
- Ça, ça perpétue le déficit
et le mauvais entretien.
- Lionel Perez était responsable
des routes sous l'administration
Coderre.
- Finalement, en 2014, on a
commencé à investir massivement.
- La clé, dit-il, est de donner
plus d'argent aux
arrondissements. À Montréal,
c'est eux qui doivent entretenir
leurs routes. Eux qui devraient,
par exemple, placer un scellant
sur l'asphalte dès
qu'une fissure apparait.
LIONEL PEREZ, chef sortant de
l'opposition, Ensemble Montréal
- Alors on voit ici comme quoi
il y a une fissure qui n'a pas
été remplie. Et au fur et
à mesure, il y a l'eau qui s'est
accumulée. Et là, on commence
comme quoi il y a eu l'effet
gel-dégel. Ça s'est répandu.
Bien ça, dans un an, ça va être
un nid-de-poule beaucoup plus
grand si on ne le corrige pas.
Actuellement, il n'y a pas de
programme d'entretien préventif
pour éviter ce genre de
situation. C'est quelque chose
que nous, dans notre plateforme,
on l'a inclus.
- 1 $ qui est investi
en prévention pour le maintien
d'une route va sauver de
6 à 10 $ en réparations qui vont
subvenir plusieurs années après.
- À peu près tout le monde
s'entend pour dire qu'il faut
investir encore plus d'argent
dans la réfection des routes
à Montréal. Petit rappel
toutefois : la Ville est
responsable de seulement 25 %
des chantiers sur
son territoire. Les autres sont
gérés soit par le MTQ,
Hydro-Québec, Énergir ou
le privé par exemple.
Comme quoi, quand il est
question de travaux à Montréal,
ce n'est jamais simple.
Ici Jean-Sébastien Cloutier,
Radio-Canada, M